[Music]
so conduct a meeting in moscow on a
range of important issues including the
situation around ukraine
catalyzes
numerous problems which have accumulated
over the previous decades in the
european and atlantic responders region
to your initiative to have another
contact
in moscow on a number of issues
including definitely the situation
around ukraine that has actually become
a catalyst of a number of great number
of problems that have piled up uh in the
euro-atlantics
we
your desire
at this difficult times to seriously
begin to think about
how the u.n will develop and how it will
uh
implement the
multilateral principle
which has over the past
years has been neglected by the west
which
began to implement one polar world we
appreciate
well your desire to have well another
round of talks at this hard time
uh in order to be able to think uh
consid consider and think properly and
in in-depth way about how we shall be
able to develop the united nations and
the true multilateralism principles and
the system
and i must say that these principles of
the true multilateralism have for a
number of years been flouted by the west
that has uh undertook the
the the attack the tactics
of
well uh instilling
into the world arena the unilateral
world order
well definitely the true multilateralism
should be underpinned by the principles
of the yearn charter and most most
importantly the principle enshrined in
it which is the sovereign quality of
nations
[Music]
and no doubt today we will talk any
other issue that you deem to be
important
is
after after dinner in the afternoon you
are scheduled to have a meeting with the
president of the russian federation
which definitely uh emphasizes the
importance that we attach to our
contacts with the united nations
a warm welcome once again so
thank you very much
i am
you know a
very committed
and they committed multilateralist based
on the values of the uncharted and
international law
i know that
we have today in
facing
the complex situation in ukraine
different interpretations about what's
happening in ukraine but that does not
limit the possibility to have a very
serious dialogue or now best we can work
to minimize the suffering of people
on the other hand
we are extremely interested
in finding ways
in order to
create the conditions for
effective dialogue create the conditions
for
a ceasefire as soon as possible create
conditions for a peaceful solution and
in this context we are also interested
in everything that can be done to
minimize the impact in different parts
of the world
we are witnessing uh
and i've been going to africa after
these visits
we are witnessing uh the dramatic
impacts of
the war in the situations that
we
have in countries that face already the
covet that face the uneven access to
resources after the covet in the
very unfair way that the
international financial system
works and
now with the increase of prices that has
accelerated it was already happening
that has accelerated
uh with war it's very important to do
everything possible to support all
countries around the world in relation
to uh
the food in relation to energy and
relation to finance
so these are
also very deep interests that i have in
the present moment to do everything
possible
to
[Music]
end war
as soon as possible and to do everything
possible to minimize the suffering of
the people and to address the impacts in
the vulnerable populations in other
parts of the world and at the same time
there are a number of other points in
the agenda that we are very much
interested in discussing in depth with
the russian federation